well the red sox bring the american
league's best record into their 90th
game of 2021 red sox piling up 11 runs
to roll over the phillies friday night
lieutenant martin perez looking for that
kind of run support today and jerry
martine has found a nice little groove
lately well it really has you know when
you look at a ball club and you look at
their fifth start around they have seven
and four with a 3.89 era you kind of
figure around a pretty good ball club
and that's exactly what martin perez is
going in into the all-star break with
gene segura will be the first to face
him as he steps in 3-2 pitch
and that one is crushed deep to left
field forget about it out of the
ballpark gene segora starts the ball
game with a solo home run one-nothing
phillies
martin perez tries to come in with a
four-seam fastball this time to try to
rush him inside and gene segura was
looking inside and did not miss it well
robot we had a problem there's no homer
hat in the dugout i don't know so it's a
bubble gum bucket hat it was bryce
harper 280 with 15 home runs he's one
for eight against martine lifetime
pounding ball
arroyo flips in there bogart's on to
first an easy turn for the double play
red sex had plenty of time to turn that
one more owen won a 5.60 era 296
opposition batting average against he's
made six starts at fenway park four
he's allowed two earned runs or fewer
alex fordugo will be the batter
out to left center field and williams
makes the diving grab as the sunglasses
pop off two outs here in the first
inning this is a kid who's never played
in fenway and he plays like unabashedly
i love the way he goes about his
business he is not scared out there and
he gets a very good jump on this ball
solo will be the batter with the runner
on first that's hoskins
and that one is crushed also to deep
left field it's off the side above the
green monster a two-run home run it's
the second homer of the day for the
fills they jump out to a three-nothing
lead i believe it was a change-up and
that was that's almost like throwing
right to his strength because his bat
speed has been a little bit slower this
year we'll bring up the catcher number
nine hit her nap hitting 179 with two
home runs
cut out and missed he sets him down his
first strikeout today and now segura who
belted a home run to start the ball game
crowd wants a strikeout and they get one
on the cut and the miss on the breaking
ball but another rough inning he gives
up the two-run shot three-nothing
philadelphia and xander bogart sitting
for the first time against matt moore
he's six for 12 a home run against the
lefty lifetime
it's a high fly ball that one deep to
left field that's way back there and she
is gone
right off the top of the plymouth rock
side yeah he was looking forward to that
and he almost for the 14th time this
season you couldn't get it off to your
tongue quick enough he jumped all over
this pitch arroyo was over five last
night with a strikeout
and on the ground to second base gloved
by segura and he throws him out side is
retired the red sox do get a run on the
home run by xander bogarts two down for
jd martinez who is in a wicked line
drive caught by harper
throw to first and down the line it goes
up against the tarp
vasquez rounding he's going to score and
it skips off nap big turn there at third
base by hernandez but he goes back and
the red sox grab another run on a
throwaway and that will load up the
bases for the red sox with two outs here
in the third and raphael devers he'll be
the batter
fly ball
left field mccutcheon says he has it and
he does and the inning is over that's a
good job by matt moore work around that
error the right-handed hitting dh today
jt rio muto
the pitch bounced over the mound
backhanded by arroyo behind second base
and christian throws him out royal had
to go a long way to his right it was a
chopper that went right over the mound
over the leaping sawamura sawamor is 1-0
chopper right at the shortstop bogarts
on three hops he has it throws them out
that's an easy one two three inning for
sawa mora who's retired all four men he
has faced bailey falter will be the new
pitcher for the fills and face sander
bogarts to lead off sixth inning
swag of the miss he got it with a change
up it squirts out of knapp's glove
bogarts is retired for the first down
here in the sixth inning two outs here
in the sixth and hunter red pro is
coming up
swag swinging a miss he went upstairs to
pick up his second strikeout of the
inning one two three go the red sox
billy falter doing his job here in the
sixth we'll move on to the seventh bill
muto with a pair of singles today he's
gone two for three he has a base runner
with one out oh two boy that was quick
that was good morning good afternoon
good night to set down real muto and two
gone josh taylor to face bryce harper
3-2 phillies top seven at fenway
and it got him picked
throwdown's gonna be dropped
and kicked around a bit he's still
having a run down going right at him for
the tag and he is frozen and segura is
out what is he doing bobby dalbeck steps
in
swing gonna miss 92 mile an hour
fastball three strikeouts for falter
six up six down it's a ten pitch seventh
inning for the young left-hander so
runners at first and second nobody out
and reese hoskins will be the batter
and a high fly ball out towards center
field toward the 379 mark and it's off
the green monster and over the head of
[ __ ] hernandez two runs will score
mccutchen read it beautifully it's a
two-run double for hoskins it's five to
two phillies and the scoreless streak
for josh tower ends at 22 innings
nobody out bag's full of fills ronald
torreish will be the batter
line drive out towards center field
that's going to drop in for basin one is
in rounding third holding there
gregorius
it's six to two philly's on top ronald
terrellis has a three hit day and the
bases remain loaded with fills and
nobody out
and that's ball four that'll force in
another run four runs of score to the
inning for the phillies all four runs
charged to the line of josh taylor
nobody out jeans girl will be the better
ground ball back toward the middle into
center field to base hit two runs are
going to score and it's misplayed by
hernandez and they hold andrew knapp at
third it's two rbis for segura he has
three today so bryce harper will step in
that one's out toward left field it's
pretty well hit for dugo is going back
it's going to be off the monster he
kicks it around
two runs are going to score harper's
going to go to second base he's got a
two-run double it's his second hit of
the inning
and the phillies keep adding on it's
11-2 that will bring up bobby dahlbach
with two outs here in the bottom of the
ninth
swag and a miss he got him he threw him
the cutter that he's able to finish off
this ball game and the phils take game
two
a resilient rebound from yesterday's
loss